guys I just want to say it's Monday I
want to thank Munn by Monday every time
I did podcast I realized everything's
alright in the world I wake up I was a
little stressed this weekend why could
you your that's right well I think my
psoriasis had a little flare-up but
that's because I ate like an [ __ ] in
in San Francisco I like my I'm becoming
friends with my psoriasis because what
happens is I go you know what I'm eating
a bunch of cheese drinking a couple
bottles of wine and why don't we top
that off with a cheesecake and by the
way I'll have a fatty steak and my skin
goes oh really you used to do that I've
known you for a while and once you get
older you have a buildup you know it's
all over your face now yeah it did from
here no it's not I promise you it's on
your face no no I have that that's from
I'm a boxer that's from boxing yep it's
not from boxing Oh bread diner face
would not be where do I have and then on
the side it's here - now there's minutes
here I promise me no that's it that's a
birthmark
that's a birthday yeah it's our big deal
spring your face no I don't know but I
just have that that might be from
training I trained okay now but I I
think that sometimes you ever wake up
and you're just stressed for no [ __ ]
reason you ever go why am i stressed
what's going on here I won't get where
I'm a little sad for the reason I shake
theirs back - yeah you shake it though I
shake it eventually have you guys all
wake up just like mad you know you're
wake up man yep sure have I wake up and
any little thing that's going on like a
noise like my dog panting or my wife or
my wife giving me instructions are
asking me lots of questions about my
future schedule annoyed that'll get me
going me too
I'll get me all kinds of bunches up -
that'll happen so sometimes I wake up
mad sometimes I wake up tired sometimes
I wake up sad rarely for me but
sometimes super rare for me I'm just
saying sometimes I wake up tight though
my chest little tight a little stressed
which is yellow well we could get a lot
of work going on I think if your agent
calls and they're going through schedule
stuff like that like I almost don't want
it I said Justin our agent I said hey
send me all the dates I've got invited
look at the man like oh my god that's a
lot of
no I just sent me in the month from now
may I give you my man maybe to me a
month from now may I give you my
schedule for man June please
okay so we got we got new on we got
Norland you shooting a movie newer we
got Norland then then we fly right to
New York then new or through the ABC up
front we'll announce my show what's an
up front up front where we announced the
new show that's that's all good
yes it's about time for you yes I then
fly back to Los Angeles on the 17th
we'll do our podcast we'll have a good
time
I then will fly right back to New York
on the 24th I'll be in Obion New York
until the oh I'll go from New York to
nollans I'll come back on on a Monday
we'll podcast on the 28th and then and
then we'll podcast Monday and Wednesday
and then I'll fly right back I'll fly
right back to nollans
Holland I'll shoot in the morning I fly
back on 30th I'll shoot the morning of
the 31st but then I'll fly I'll fly the
31st I'll fly that afternoon to
Minnesota Minnesota but we're not even
get there yet House of comedy well house
a comedy I'll do that 31st set first and
2nd of June all good house of comedy
come see me
you rest there a little rest there a
little bit I love doing stand-up and
then I'll and then I'll fly back to LA
I'll fly back to LA and then I'm gonna
and then I'm gonna do this I'm gonna go
right to after we podcast Monday on
Wednesday I'm gonna go right to know I'm
gonna do Raleigh's I'm gonna do Raleigh
North Carolina
good night because I need to get myself
going for my my show on the 20th right
I'm working yeah I want to make it
perfect then I'll come back then I'll
fly right - oh then I'm gonna go to
Hawaii the NEB I'll go - why you're
special
yeah I'll go to Y which is awesome for
the LMS and then I'm gonna go I'll come
back here I'll come back will pod can I
know what I hear when I hear the school
schedule do I look oh don't look like a
mule
I'm sorry duck don't look like a mule
yeah I'm just gonna be carrying the show
no I'm back to the show I'm not missing
the show I'm missing one now no I'm
missing one day I'm just going back yeah
I think you're at the mule what what
movie
in New Orleans oh oh that's the movie
think like a dog and then I and then out
so I'll do Hawaii with the family I'm
excited about that that's the case yeah
that's a big cash doesn't count
don't tell me I'll come back Podcast
I'll fly I'll fly to Portland and then
I'll go to China yeah I'll go to China
well holy in China 24th to the 2nd of
July we went through this oh yeah yeah
and then I know 24th try not the Sun I'm
dying movie then I'm back I'll go to sir
Q's and I'll go to Tampa and then I'll
shoot my special in and I'll shoot my
special xx Thalia Hall in Chicago that's
just a lot of traveling and ball playing
right I'll miss the podcast only once
you think I know I already worked it out
I'm seeing going once
yeah I worked it out which is incredible
that I'm only missing no no no this will
you don't forget to miss in time you
know how it is you know I could hold it
yeah I doubt it's more than one it's all
good that I travel I'm not complaining
I'm so [ __ ] lucky I get to do
everything I want but it's just when you
travel you know hotels it's just a bit
I'm gonna need a specific way now I'll
do my diet and you put me in Mall of
America I'm next - got to have Cinnabon
I know I can't eat any that costume not
me my skin goes give it your your skin
like rock it shinier and more pliable
yeah your skin gets plush we thrive
I find myself envying people with with
who can wear shorts now oh yeah oh by
the way people are so nice they come up
to me like dude I have psoriasis -
everybody has a cure there was joke
about your psoriasis now I will know I
do oh you do I do
hey you can use my schism that's
outrageous
you've got some you got some peanut
colored shoes on roasted peanuts roasted
peanut
those are a little peanut bro you got
any suede high-top sneakers roasted
peanut dude how about uh you know I like
myself pair of tight jeans how about I
bust my jeans onstage saw that
three-piece set came on out yeah those
people went first of all your standup
okay you dick fantastic really your
three-piece dick set yeah amazing
three-piece set standing ovations your
baby burning ovation baby bird he
finally got his shine
well 10 outdo you with your legs how the
[ __ ] do you find jeans that the the
determine called AG if we chin looked
like an art a fact they have like if I
have like a stretch light and so did the
G stars have like a stretch material and
I'm how can I like real bad you G now
let's don't now you are you are XL or an
XXL depends what it is
depends what it is well guess let me
guess your your suit size because I'm a
40 regular
you uh you 48 yeah I'm 48 long damn it's
a big boy
48 48 regular in 48 regular you 48 long
pretty long long but in college you were
probably 46 regular baby I don't know I
was bigger in college
I'm steak kid 260 pounds Oh dad my
senior years okay but but they made me
bulk up then with the beam and of 1819
Sophia 222 finish still that's still
respectable size to 20 inch to 20 still
big kid yeah Congrats
thanks man there you go you bullies boy
now you bully boy me and junior bully
boys a couple players bully brothers
yeah
he blew out his jeans the weekend before
I don't why people keep blowing out
jeans oh yeah I look at him differently
now all that I saw is Tom if you yeah
well he Dwarfs us you know that yes fad
do I grew up with that digit of stupid I
grew up with that fat dick you might
miss ridiculous no I think I walk around
like look at my dick a nice size I went
it was like everything stopped take a
big ol [ __ ] yeah he's trying to cover it
but he couldn't with his hands his hands
weren't big enough to cover it oh you
would have loved this and you would have
called these guys out so I I was doing
my show in uh Minnesota I got on stage
with to my right and it's just a full
table look like Sons of Anarchy she's a
full table of Hell's Angels real Hells
Angels Oh like fully patch cells angels
jeez and I watched all that [ __ ] on that
roll is that as I color so cool I wanna
be in that Club
see I can never run with those guys now
so they bought the VIP meet-and-greet
so I seem in line like Hells Angels by
meeting feats and they get them they're
nice as hell they were dying laughing in
the show that's to get lined and they
you have the full though I forget the
guys name big day or something he's huge
I'm sure there's a picture out there
somewhere of a [ __ ] giant six six big
dude holy patched-up yeah and I was like
Hells Angels huh all right that's cool
man glad you guys came up he had fun and
I was like yeah so we questioned this
guy's but I don't have time here we
should do a podcast or something they're
definitely not doing that definitely
they don't know that stuff well here's
how we run our business and then it's
all fake yeah but and then he goes once
you come to club house once chemical
house was may I show you around I went
oh I'd like to there's a part of me that
wants to I just can't they be finding
all this stuff you read on the newspaper
I'm like yeah and then he's like
seriously kind of sapphires though I'm
satisfied we run that [ __ ] it's a strip
club yeah oh yeah oh yeah and then you
know there's a line of people waiting to
talk to me right and they're walking off
me to know goes yo all the birds are
sucking off the boys come south fires I
went so birds that's a great that's the
English direction for girl I I feel like
if I were you I wouldn't go to the I
could go to the clubhouse I feel because
I'm not nobody's gonna get jealous right
the actor but with you you got the ears
those guys are tough I looked at Jay and
I went man I've always like I'm up I've
I used to read books on biker gangs the
Hells Angels and the Mongols and all
that stuff I was so into it and so I
look at them it's almost like you know
how you feel when you meet athletes I
was like damn cuz I know a lot about
them I want to talk to him and just kind
of spend the night with them well but
then yeah I thought God the pros and
cons pros have a grand old time with the
Hells Angel I get some good stories cons
I get decked it addicted to meth with
them and I'm fighting they're enforced
well they don't do they don't do meth
they sell no Matt but allegedly there
are ok guys I'm N
there's some more so take it easy no
allegedly there are certain gangs that
maybe sell meth no fur I like the guy we
we met for a little bit about
merchandise he does some merchandise for
the Hells Angels he knows some of the
guys and I guess certain chapters and
and I said he said the best thing I've
ever heard about the Hells Angels
already goes I said what will you say
your friends let me go you hang up the
clubhouse he goes yes sometimes I go
what's that like egos do you just got to
remember you're not a grizzly bear
that's all
not a grizzly bear I go what do you mean
he goes if you study grizzly bears you
can study grizzly bears for 30 years get
up close to them take pictures of them
write about them take do movies about
them but always remember you're not a
[ __ ] grizzly bear yeah and if you
think you can go pet that grizzly bear
or live with the grizzly bears I hang
out with the grizzly bears you're gonna
get [ __ ] eaten CIT goes and he goes
when I'm there at the chat that there
you keep a low profile and you're
respectful because there could be a guy
from another chapter who doesn't know
you yeah you didn't give a [ __ ] about
you so you just got it I don't want that
I like I just want to chill man I'd
loved it I'm sure I do that I'm should
be fun I'd love to do that it sounds so
cool I bet I'd get so many cool stories
maybe in a bit from it but I just like
when I did when I did odds they were of
I was younger I wouldn't yeah when I was
when I did oz that TV show Chuck cedar
was no longer at Hells Angel but he used
to be he was a he a head of the chapters
of the president or something like that
don't know but chuck was there and so a
lot of his buddies would come on set and
they're there they are
they are if you're gonna be an outlaw
that's that's that's a no you don't
remind me of like a modern day in that
I'm not this is no disrespect but it's
like modern day like pirate yeah so
camera it's exactly right so pirate
that's a great way of the big beard
there's making the wrong dudes like some
of the dudes are actually really
good-looking muscular dudes you're like
all that bit big guy was a good-looking
dude yeah yeah but if I was like if I
went to an artist went hey draw me a
Hells Angel against was it what I need a
reference I'd go just draw me Hells
Angel yeah he would have drawn this guy
yeah yeah exactly like out of like if
you were casting you Hells Angel movie
you went that looks - dude that's Pro
there's too much that's too on the nose
yeah it's exactly how you'll know this
no no what
that's how you look is stealing your
girl know this that that they get they
don't have any trouble getting laid with
those colors and that look no but also
they they're the you know they're girls
on the back of that bike or willing to
do some things to they're trying to show
you a good time I'm all if I was younger
I'd be so about it I'd like to have a
kid I can't die who knows I'm sure
nothing to happen it's so interesting to
me they're the life it and I'm for what
a reason I'm drawn to it yeah reason I
mention that because I and I'm telling
this one was like well you're tough guy
this I'm not like them I can't I don't
have I was kind of compassion me that I
can't do what they do like I can't go
beat up another gang because they live
on another Street well I think a lot of
it also can be like I don't think all of
you ever read that book no I read that
book that's a great great book so this
this gentleman was part of the DEA and
he infiltrates and goes into Hell's
Angel it's called undercover he goes in
what happens oh he loves it so much he
starts to do drugs and something they
have to pull him out for you it's to in
you got any had to flip on him he got
sucked
yeah to any and they have a my camera
doing drugs so the the thing you know
what the hells angels did office they
have a good representation well when he
went in to infiltrate being like a Hells
Angel they have him on video doing drug
and stuff yeah all that was thrown out
they know what the [ __ ] deal I know
they know oh yeah any have to fake a
murder so they're like if you want to
get patch you got to do this so they the
LA home of tell a but whatever PD was
they made it look like a crime scene
like you did it and they showed him they
they show them pictures like hey we took
care of it man
yeah it's it's so much not under a lot
of what we hear they look at the way
things are the reality of how things are
run versus what we all myth and lore is
probably very different oh honey there
it anything yeah but they're just
regular dude that then a day they chose
this life yeah well I just things I'd I
can't live with anxiety of knowing if I
come across a Mongol there's that you
know I I don't like when someone's upset
at me when something's upsetting me I'm
happy 'pl that
Nate Diaz is that I call this coach like
yo man I don't need any you know I don't
know you don't like I just I like
everyone so every part like if they were
like Kate Brennan you're out see the
best fighter here we need to get the
money from that guy go there if you like
dude I do my kids gifts oh my god get
that man I get that what are we gonna do
though you think I don't [ __ ] know
Mike you know what I'm gonna cover you
this time I'm gonna go to the ATM take
money out and tell my guy I ran a scene
in Rocky where he's got to break the
guy's thumb think I was taking my jacket
don't break my thumb's I gotta work take
my jacket
it's a good jacket keep your jacket keep
your jacket it doesn't doesn't take his
money yeah I'm just not made for that
life yeah and I'll tell you what though
also this that Hell's Angel logo Oh they
support that and they cover that by any
means necessary
I have a friend be caught wearing it if
you don't if you have our know you'll
have a friend who owns a clothing
company who decided to mimic the Hells
Angel logo on the back and it just said
California was a different flag
underneath that idea
oh well Hells Angels ran up to him in
Beverly Hills and came a little warning
you have to take those off this website
I respect that I think I think a lot I
think I think it's cool and I sold their
fashion is sick the jean jackets a
passion [ __ ] that [ __ ] pretty cool yeah
it all starts right about the Vietnam
War and all that and they didn't have
any you know any say and they were these
Randy Barger this has name he started
yeah no disrespect this was my throat
cancer
yeah from smoking or whatever you ever
seen some of the girls they run with
mm-hmm but Hells Angel motorcycle hose
no I'm just kidding to put something
though girls we gotta figure you're
gonna have some what do they call the
Hells Angel groupies biker [ __ ] I
don't know there's they call them tears
they do on their property you have
changed I've watched a show on this they
do have their man's name on chain around
them god damn right they do which I
celebrate Brendon what that's their
choice
I got a policy man's bike I don't know
if they do
that is what it is there are a lot of
girls in love that's a bad example
yeah I'm trying to find that State
Navarro that's not our health Angela
anyhow I don't know cool stuff though I
don't know why I meant two sons of
anarchy was good
they probably laugh at that but then
sons of anak use yeah I lost I lost
interest in that sure after a while me
too
I'm thinking like three seasons deep
words and even then I just felt a lot of
love but yeah they're doing a new one
with the Mayan the Mayans yeah my boy
Rocco's on that gym
they bought your they want me out you
know Rocco from one me audition for yeah
that's a whine oh that's right you know
Rocco Rocco is my arranger raindrops
yeah yeah good guy great guy he's in it
that's cool man nice got a bike again
I'm such a [ __ ] that I don't even want
I would not ride a motorcycle cuz I'm
afraid I no no dude I'm afraid biker
gang I have a big hog you jump on the
back oh alright or dude no no this what
we do oh I would have the fat hog like
yeah and then he in a little sidecar
yeah only if I can have an Uzi yeah he
doesn't Newsies and I want to spray
people as I write if you [ __ ] with me
like I'm the guy that guy he's a [ __ ]
and I'm like and I want the big glasses
the old-fashioned glasses with the
letter [ __ ] ass yeah I [ __ ]
homo me I have little bombs I have all
kinds of things you're seeing that
you're seeing that and you your big
daddy and I'm baby mmm
family guys watch out for a baby Big
Daddy's tough yes
no go down there's one go down chin you
see the red one with a little dude in
there chillin there we are there we are
now that that's what we want that looks
super safe too super safe if you get
sideswiped it'd be fun though man yeah
for a minute thing is for a minute to it
I need my cell is my weaponry I have
lots of hidden weaponry there you go
that's what I'm [ __ ] you know that one's
weak that doesn't look great time I
wanna win Oh
I give this in some hang time I've never
been a motor shot guy but we've been
scared more seconds first thing I ever
got was that that slingshot thing I did
yeah went down PCH yeah nope I'm not a
motorcycle guy I could be that's why
don't I don't get on him because I know
I'll like it too much and then I'll
probably crash I like standing what they
say like special forces guys like most
special you're not a special forces guy
until you got at least everybody yep you
have a motorcycle and one divorce under
your belt yeah you know the when I was
with frank grillo um I won't say his
name but the captain of SEAL Team six
was there and they were doing this thing
about doing this movie it was a
consultant and he had a he and his
friends motorcycle who had been killed
and it was pretty wild
just Eve there he was and it's this
badass bike but of course but of course
he has a motorcycle but of course not me
I Drive a very safe car see I feel like
well I guess some fighters in those
motorcycles and cowboy and trash Brown
and motorcycle stuff like that primer I
free who I was fighting but they go man
if you win this fight you know Harley
didn't let you pick any motorcycling
pretty cool very cool that I feel like
that's a bad gift so I can ruin my leg
and not fight I feel like that for
rappers say if you sell this many
tickets we give you a bunch of codeine
you know like we're gonna give you drugs
it's not good given your fighters motor
so you guys for my gym from my boxing
gym love works were we're just injured
and the two brothers really bad on the
motorcycle the motorcycles yesterday I
think what they're on the same bike or
they were on two bikes together and they
got [ __ ] up and yeah really bad
motorcycles you can't really well cars
don't see you they're not looking for it
yeah but even if it's not your fault
your fault everyone says I like most
times two cars well guess what it
doesn't matter we're gonna wreck its
game [ __ ] and if a truck hits you you're
really in trouble well the truck hit you
whether in a goddamn humming well at
least in a car you got you know just an
innocent
you got to steal three four steel walls
around you but I feel like if you live a
life like a Delta Force or UFC fighters
those high stressful jobs to me I go
when I'm outside
doing that I want a more relaxed life I
don't have to deal with that pressure
all the time or there's that motto die
young and leave a good-looking corpse
you know live [ __ ] live lift hard and
fast people they make sense it's a long
life you're speaking you're talking like
a 35 year old life is long women
you're talking like a 35 year old you're
right and most most people who get in
those kinds of accidents are in their
teens and 20s you watch these guys on
Instagram doing wheelies and standing on
their bikes on the highway going 60
miles an hour and all I do is cringe
because I'm an old man to me I'm an old
man I don't want to see a young man hurt
you got your whole life Adi
dude have you have you ever had this
happen I was obviously in the goddamn
mall all weekend at Mall of America a
place is so big but I was at a Foot
Locker looking at these cakes I'm
obsessed with their max once you don't
know what the [ __ ] those are it doesn't
matter so I like those golden gooses
though anyways shout to the kid who came
in the weatherspoon Nikes but I was at
the mall and there's this mom you know
that mom was smiling like straight off
the scent of eight-mile I'll put it that
way and she was yelling at her kid have
you ever wanted to say step in I felt so
bad for the kid man the way she was
talking I want the daddy I'm like to do
something so she's pushing baby and
other kids maybe six and the right bias
and she goes something like Papa went
you like these in the mom maybe just
having a bad day man that bitch's
bipolar just goes off you don't shut the
[ __ ] up you don't shut the [ __ ] up and
just start getting in her face oh my god
man I don't know everything about
parenting but I know that ain't the way
that's not and then he got outside and
she goes you little [ __ ] you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] I told you we going store
you don't ask for anything
I [ __ ] - I was like oh my god I just
stared at him as a cop man you can't you
can't mess with people's kids
yeah probably touchy puts a hand on her
I should probably do something yeah I
get secure like what do you do it's
always have that problem when they see a
domestic violence yes
that's where they get hurt cuz you see a
guy like a lot of times the stores where
the guys hitting the woman the woman the
man the cop comes in grabs the man the
woman attacks the cop yeah it's like
what the oh you guys have a weird
Namek here yeah sexual like there's some
[ __ ] where you guys fight you beater I
know but with King I know a woman with
kids that's different then Oh like
what's wrong you know what you're doing
here when she goes out she's gonna
[ __ ] eat yep there's a woman I know
there's I used to work with this woman
she told me her friend she's she's fat
she's a big woman her husband is skinny
and and she'll get her husband to a
point where her husband will put a
beating on her and I go that's terrible
and she goes no no no no she likes it
she goes it makes her feel like a woman
so she'll cry and stuff and then so we
hear her and we used to come in and what
that [ __ ] you know and we hear him
beating her you know I don't know
beating her like you know he'd take his
belt off Friday wailing you take his
without the I love a wolf yep take his
belt off hit her with a belt hit her and
that was hand fighting and stuff right
she's a big girl
and then he's here yeah now you [ __ ]
and here and then your novel Venga job
then you hear see baby like wait for it
wait for it
ten minutes later five years later she's
downing that that was there talking
routine that [ __ ] it that well people
are so complicated and weird
relationships sexuality it's obviously
what they were into law the cops - they
said the worst domestic violence is
amongst gays if two dudes because dude
you know there are yeah [ __ ] and then
officer hey bro yeah it's - bro
yeah by day yep and they suck each
other's dick I was and then when there's
passion involved they're fighting like
bros but they're trying to they did they
base become chimpanzee and try and rip
each other - or man did I ever tell you
the story I may have told you this
there was a comedy club called stand-up
New York and a guy named Nicholas he was
a big big Queen he was by his own those
are his own words he was just a he was a
giant redhead Nicholas I wish our his
name and he was he was probably five
eleven maybe six feet and a good he
might have been he might have actually
been about six to four hundred oh good
good three three bills right you know
what
think of think of ROI think of run a
country yeah the Roy Nelson but with
what what very gay and with very red
hair and just and just so sweet and
loved me and I loved him he said he was
just no and he was just always like you
are very funny honestly you don't have a
lot of great jokes but you're so
physical it's amazing see the throat was
either he was manager Nicolas was any
was smart and wonderful I loved him and
I always thought I always just looked at
him as a big girl honestly he was just
so feminized just a big girl he wore
like shorts that he would roll up he
even though he was big in the heavy
dressed like big framed and he was yes
he dressed just like you and he was vain
but in a good and and so on my side and
so [ __ ] great and one day one day
there was a dude there who was being a
dick and he pulled out his wallet and
offered the bouncer a thousand dollars
to fight him and the bouncer was just a
big guy wasn't a fighter and the guy
boss was like now I look to just you got
to leave sir and he turned and looked at
Nick and called him a [ __ ] and Nick
went Nick I he ditched the he ditched
the lizard he turned and he had been
future I go he'd been called that name
and probably been beaten up as a kid and
dude I'm telling the truth I saw it's
like well Marty McFly chicken he got he
goes he got in front of ouncer he goes
listen [ __ ] I'll take you outside and
I'll squash you like a [ __ ] bug so
you just make a move and I'll tell you
what I'll let you hit me first why don't
you do that you little [ __ ]
you little and he punked this [ __ ]
macho guy and the guy was big himself
but the guy looked at guy who shows up
he looked at this giant redhead he
dropped my f-bomb oh this guy's gonna
fight me and he's bigger he's he might
be gay but that doesn't make him any
less tough and you could say I saw him
in such a different way because I went
you were bullied as a kid you were
teased for being gay and this guy just
called you a [ __ ] the triggered zone
and that triggered something because
obviously that were for him this is
backed by the way baby before that word
with that Woodward was acceptable when I
when this happened this was 1992 Jeffery
now you're in symmetry maybe it was 93
or four it doesn't matter he said it and
that was it and I he punked this [ __ ]
dude out the out of the club humor
I just never said you are I looked and I
go you know me I love that tough stuff I
go I'm gonna dude you can turn it on hi
you guys oh you have no idea you have no
idea what would have happened to him cuz
I would have [ __ ] destroyed him
I go you can fight he goes yeah I can
fight I can fight well and I'm
impossible to hurt I never got penny oh
yeah because he's faced with that why he
will set yeah you know I swore her oh
you know he'd be impossible you know you
know those guys yeah you people teed off
on how many times did you punch did you
punch Roy Roy Roy Roy Alton in the face
I mean you provide those in face didn't
face him I feel like will sassy hit him
it just it booked a flight than that
what a turn wouldn't matter he's just
too big too strong too angry haven't
seen real in a while of will will has
FTS fat teenager syndrome he's never
gotten over it and he's got inner rage
he's got a you know what he's doing
right now
you don't worry is that the Super
Troopers - no no no sir Louisiana he's
starring in a movie with Mel Gibson and
Frank Grillo and Naomi Watts
starring as an embossed level in Atlanta
joe carnahan smokin aces the gray he's
doing fine yeah
God put him in that he's got a black
beard and he's a bad [ __ ] got
all the scenes with those guys he's
having at the time of his life
there it is [ __ ] yeah Wales woman was
talented ever what's that will so town
talk yeah oh yeah dude I think I can
tell the story Frank and Frank and Mel
Gibson this this this script is so
[ __ ] good I wants to give it away but
joe carnahan wrote it but Frank a movie
you're into beer no no no this is boss
level that Frank's told right now with
with Sasso and Mel Gibson's and Naomi
Watts
apparently Mel Gibson hit they were
doing a fight scene and Mel Gibson hit
Frank and like Frank thought his jaw was
dislocated and Mel Gibson goes come here
come here
sit down sit down I got it I got you I
got you
and he did some [ __ ] to his neck and his
jaw like it and Franco's I'm better
because ya know I think I'll [ __ ] Mel
Gibson just fix my [ __ ] jaw that's
fun is really wild here I love that guy
look at those [ __ ] I think they're
having a good time how about Frank
Grillo at 52 a movie star oh I know
kill knows that use that Instagram of
his part
shred ceases Christ not natural shred
shred look at that body come on what the
[ __ ] Frank [ __ ] off dude hey Rock
everybody else what what do you got to
say about my boy look at that I taxed my
go dude Jesus I just went Jesus Christ
he's in phenomenal shape
that's stupid he's always been able he
can walk by a weight set though when I
met him II just ya know I hear those
guys yeah yeah now does he do all the
tea or tea or what do you think he's
doing yams full of steroids oh not dude
he's eating the same tacos as canal yeah
yeah no he walked by a weight set you
can get shredded no I've heard that from
a lot of guys now would you say him and
rock have the same dealer or what do you
think's going on there and I talked to
you about this yeah now does that faint
in his tummy right no I know does he his
source straight from Sly Stone
I love this work he's just a little he's
just a little shredded that's all no
that's completely natural he does look
[ __ ] great though yeah he does with
that hair [ __ ] off Frank [ __ ] off with
your he's a handsome guy get him back on
the podcast I want to interrogate him he
is a handsome son of a [ __ ] I have
never been out with that guy in my life
I've known him 20 years maybe more I've
never been out with him and I'm saying
never never have I been out with him
sitting down eating dinner where girls
from another table or from a bar didn't
start talking to us oh he's strikingly
it's so annoying I'm like jeez he makes
you and me look like [ __ ] well you do
alright if you and him were out it'd be
it'd be it'd be a problem no that's if
it's mean him I'm so much bigger and
younger I look like his [ __ ] side
piece yeah like I look like I'm strong
commander swallows well Stevie showed up
when we were doing Santa he showed up a
day later and we were in where we were
in Denver and Stevie walks in I'm eating
walks in I'm having dinner at the bar in
this really nice place in Denver he
walks in in a camo hat camo pants and a
tight white t-shirt really was Kim and a
knapsack that was that had strings
strings on the message were you know
just here well no the knapsack was not a
real knapsack it was like a little
satchel that you put over your back
that's strings I don't wear that I was
like Stevie you look
[ __ ] gay and you look like I flew you
into bangle sit and you have a bottom
and you you shave your forms I can't
have this I can't have your - well
shaved your hair if you will mail it you
that will lose here's perfect you have a
little well yet a little a camo cap on
it was a cat wasn't a baseball yeah it
looked like you look like you just got
the night off from a [ __ ] thunder
down under' even he said he goes I look
like your boyfriend shirt [ __ ] do and
now I gotta work I'll get out a
hamburger because I really work up an
appetite having sex with girls if you
don't mind no for your French it's
[ __ ] okay Gronk with Frank's son that
on set yeah Gronk is in the movie wasn't
funny men hardening yeah by bad itch I
think I'm not better actor than him
though Frank anyways um hey yeah the
hell Frank no Carnahan oh yeah come in I
haven't seen him in a while he's always
at boxing birth yeah I don't think
Carnahan takes me seriously as an actor
Nathan [ __ ] up and it's okay though
that's all right you see me at my best
and he seen you here he loved our
sketches oh I love them I'd love to do
those again I get some of that relief
like with doing those sketches on below
the belt like tomorrow sketch that we're
doing we added in the you know Charlotte
wins the the world champion boxers the
brothers well I have this condition
where I'm the third brother and there
but there were triplets it's crime
they're in on it thank god they're not
otherwise it won't work
have you seen what's-his-name they come
BK the he was an Olympian [ __ ] blogs
okay um no BK they the kid boxer I'll
find it whatever Billy Joe Saunders I
want to go how would he is he gonna
fight anybody like Canelo is he gonna
find anybody like triple G well triple G
they you know if they make them you know
to be a mandatory death fight Billy Joe
Saunders for the
title so that'd be what what do you
think of that fight uh I'm a huge Billy
Joe Saunders fan huge Billy Joe some
little biased but I think Billy Joe
Saunders could get it done really big
great fight though great fight cuz he's
you know there's another day at
Sunderland another dude at a sutherland
who is olympian who moves like you can't
touch his time yeah
he has one pretty boy pretty boy you're
super ways to go yeah he became close to
the same okay not not close to what the
level were talking about though he's not
he's a lot of work not a lot of work
right cuz right now he's not guys he's
on this conversation he's not no he's
just too young Josh Kelley track there's
a long way yesterday go Josh future will
do the three good know destroyed this
poor our meaning kid that would that was
kind of a given that's a warm-up thing
right well it's just you know get on
triple G to take the fight you know stay
on the card you some kind of engine yeah
how about we start with the first one
that you talked about the tunnel in Las
Vegas where there's you know thousands
of people living in them underneath Las
Vegas is a labyrinth New York had this
too you know but how about Vegas and
they go into it and they show pictures
so this deep beneath baby's glittering
like slides a sinister labyrinth in
inhabited by poisonous spiders in a man
nicknamed the troll who weld an iron bar
but especially there's 200 miles of
flooded tunnels also home to thousands
of people who eke out a living in the
strip's dark underbelly what I read this
I was like what wait so so a friend who
lives in Vegas she's like you didn't
know people live alone I'm like that's
not real
she was sleeping like kind of spiders I
mean whatever [ __ ] wizard they live
on and bungalow I think you switch and
I've seen this before to look at this
and they everything is elevated because
the flood you see those people they
thought a ton of people are gonna die
last week last summer because of the
flooding
you know what bums me out though yeah
you know it's people when others like
researching stuff you know it bums me
out there's kids down there they've got
like stuffed toys and like for all the
other stuff really makes me sad what
kids grown up in there look at that
it's big to foreigners square feet for a
person that family to live you know what
else is a bummer they're saying like
there's a lot of former like soldier
with PTSD down there and like homeless
and drug addicts you imagine the rape in
the crime that's going on down there
that goes unreported
I'm sure or it's just an organizer you
are the worst is he on the ground in
Hungary have you seen that no oh my god
they did vice did a thing on that oh you
wouldn't with kiddos and so it might be
Romania it's just like I couldn't
believe it's a hole oh my god city right
they live underground oh I see that they
kill him it's crossed repeal drug kill
them no no I'm I'm I'm bite Romania time
I stood another meeting in time I said
another thing it's in the Middle East
somewhere oh maybe it's Brazil where
that I know they the homeless people
yeah they kill him some things are so
[ __ ] terrible oh I say they're so
just good let's move on chill what else
you got
yeah people live under the the point is
people live under get [ __ ] Vegas the
whole entire community that lives
underground and Vegas with nothing I
sent you that much camps I send you a
Donald Glover baby game you know uh
childish candy ecology don't say [ __ ]
oh yeah [ __ ] video though right huh
yeah he's a genius you should see on
Sarah alive he killed it [ __ ] he's a
genius that guy's special it was just so
weird to you don't seen it I saw the
video just his shiny parts but not it
wasn't like thank you so we're gonna
wear tight pants and just like like no
shirt but was a weird and eerie and
interest I didn't like it and he's but
he's my top three favorite entertainers
I wasn't too thought I wasn't I'm still
on board that [ __ ] all the way
no matter what did you see something
like really special about those deep
that I just found it I just found it to
be very perverse and thought-provoking
of
gun it's definitely like that's what I
liked about it like the gun thing was it
wasn't even make understand it was
people are dying so I always say this
about gun control and a lot of problems
in this country I know you got your side
I know you got your side all good right
and neither sides talking to each other
and people feel very strongly meanwhile
people are still shooting meanwhile
people still dying
meanwhile the patients still sick
meanwhile we still got we still got
people dying there were no so that's
kind of what are you saying that's right
yeah and the way he did it quick like
cool that was good
yeah and that's real so it didn't move
me it was disturbing and I like that
it's disturbing it disturbed me got his
point goose well made yeah but the music
itself wasn't no he's right
I'm on board with that dude smart guy
welcome to the child can be okay you
know he's the star of the new Star Wars
as well well he should be
and speaking of black people let me just
real quickly mention I got a lot of
emails when I responded to them about my
kanye comment I didn't hear what Kanye
had said so I don't know and I still
have a promising reference that book
well that's well that books a great book
so I mean it's an important book that's
all its protected the problem is and I
agree with the people and they say this
is your only given that guy's
perspective you know they know like
we're not given the other person I was
all I was trying to say was this any
victim narrative I was talking about
does I've not heard that come out of
black people's mouths I've heard that
come out of liberal left-wing white
people and so they they are what they do
is they frame the debate in certain way
there are other perspectives to look at
in any problem whether it's the black
problem whether it's whatever gun
control so you have to look at all
different sides
Thomas soul has a different outlook at
the black man who grew up in Harlem he's
a scholar out of Stanford University I
took the time to read his book I thought
it was very thought-provoking and he
backs it up with he's a very he's a
renowned scholar doesn't mean you
believe in his idea it means he
regurgitated his yeah it means it means
that I I am very intrigued by his
examples on what he said doesn't mean as
a black
oh no no that's just what you need
exactly what you need but I'm tired of
the only one narrative that I hear out
of the liberal media I want to hear a
lot of different perspectives that's all
I was saying and I had some good talks
with intelligent or intelligent black
listeners thank you for like Nigel and
some other people who emailed me I
appreciate it so I was not saying that I
did not hear you know I'm not a big I've
never been a big fan of Kanye's I think
he might be a little unstable I'm not a
big fan of Trump's although I give him
credit for that [ __ ] Korea [ __ ]
although Korea doesn't I'll see they
can't like don't know why you guys give
them credit for this well because you
can as Koreans are very macho a very
tough they're not gonna admit their
chick kim jong you yeah but there's also
other there's also other perspectives
that say try it's not the reason look at
me right now and I would I would very
strongly disagree with that Trump that
Trump doesn't deserve all the credit
Cruz and I believe let me say it again
some heat let me say as a guy as a guy
who doesn't who didn't who's been a
critic of Trump's doesn't like the guy
personally it's all I want to say this
out loud well I believe after seven
decades on harder than drama Trump
deserves credit know ready all the
credit for kim jong un's conciliatory
gestures and coming to South Korea he's
scared shitless of that guy and I
actually think that North Korea thinks
that Trump is unstable and are very
worried about a preemptive strike and
they were not under other
administration's cuz they knew they
wouldn't do that like Obama and stuff
Trump is just unstable enough in their
minds to get them very worried credit so
so so once again me a lot for sure
though once again yes I give them all
the credit
I do you notice you know what happened
under Obama after eight years and I hear
you they got them they got themselves
about eight to ten nuclear weapons no no
that's what happened and and I was and
by the way I was a supporter of Obama in
that because I believed in diplomacy but
as you get older you change your mind
leaning towards more money as you get
older you just change your mind as you
get older you go you go this has been a
big critic of Trump's and in this case
he was [ __ ] right how about that there
[ __ ] you got to admit when you're
mistaken
real quick on that there was like you
know there's a there's a time where both
presidents were walking on a bridge no
microphones no nothing
so the North Korean president and South
Korean president were just walking and
talking
they had Korean lip-readers see what
they're talking about the majority of
what they came out of his mouth was
Trump and nuclear weapons and do new
denuclearization there you go
we just have no doubt about that I've
come too late now you know as a current
Korean culture it would be considered
losing face for them to say that they
were afraid of Trump I don't think
they're matically for different nerves
pharmacy would be that we have decided
to come together on our own on our own
accord enough is enough and all that
stuff but geopolitically Trump you all
the credit people will tell you
aggressive yeah what else you get a
chance all right
ken Jeong who's also currently my boy he
had a stand-up show in Phoenix and
stand-up live where we do our shows that
heard and he ended up well I don't know
if he saved the woman but he thought
this woman was heckling him she was
having a seizure and the people like
help or help and he thought he was
getting heckled he's like all right and
like no seriously she needs help he
jumps off the stage a doctor yeah
Kenzo do legit legit doctor and a
practicing doctor yeah well we
definitely helped her out until the
paramedics arrived did all that and then
continued on with the show and
apparently the show was amazing shot
Batson finished
hence [ __ ] hilarious so Ken let me
illustrate him on here you become a
weekend I'll call him I love him well we
can't let's see can be loved the [ __ ]
doctor
and then he's yeah he's got his doctor
and then he decides to become a movie
star well done did he go doctor comma he
went doctor practicing doctor continued
to practice but all through his improv
career I've got an improv did a lot of
improv started working God I think the
first big job he got was on knocked up
yeah the doctor he was great on there
and then was knie was still practicing
medicine he's still out of practice for
a long time and then finally just got to
a point where he's too busy he made it
he's [ __ ] awesome hilarious yeah did
you guys see the deleted scenes for Ken
Jong's deleted scenes I knocked up yes
it was incredible yeah it was incredibly
he's very funny man so funny and he's
and maybe the nicest person on the
planet
superbee seems like a great guy I can't
wait to have him on we'll have him on
alright so this one sucks for Kevin Hart
they don't know this is that he's been
investigating he was arrested so Kevin
Hart's friend a guy named JT Jackson who
I've seen around to like in comic clubs
before apparently he was the one that
was responsible for that extortion tape
Oh with Kevin know so that's one of his
buddies that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's it
that's a desperate buddy so you - that's
Kevin's responses when he found out
mind-blown hurt at a loss for words and
simply so his buddy was the one filmer
tore his know that idea concocted the
extortion plan oh sell it God how did
they find out I guess it was
indefinitely default yeah well yeah
earliest year Hart was caught up in a
sex tape extortion attempt and according
to me his longtime friend Jonathan Todd
TJ Jack's is now facing two felony
counts
Jackson has appeared in several films
with Hart and most recently Marlon
Wayans Netflix movie naked was charged
with one attempted extortion
goddamn apparently Hart was shocked Wow
and heart puts mind-blown hurt at a loss
for words simply and complete this weep
at the moment if it's your heart was on
will unknowingly video tapes having sex
with a woman in Las Vegas last summer
when the news broke he merely did damage
control by pausing his pregnant wife I'm
Jackson produced in actual video teaser
about the sex tape requested an
undisclosed amount of money
I guess being hard to hang on doesn't
pay the bills Wow that's him what what a
piece of [ __ ] alright
that's Shamar more talking about that
guy like he believes that the guy's
probably innocent well if the
investigators look into it they just
don't make claim
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] about rumors
and stuff like that you ain't do this
[ __ ] to Kevin talk to each other
do you know you definitely did it though
huh yeah that's a bummer
well that's I mean oh can you imagine
just if you think what a piece of [ __ ]
you can't do stuff like that
it ruined because I feel like Kevin be
the friend if you were that financially
strapped you went up to her I came in I
need a little help he's probably in the
house such a good person yeah Kevin it's
nobody's extort him for money
I [ __ ] love that guy that's a bummer
man people do weird things sometimes out
of desperation this guy was like I don't
know why I look at people's faces and I
kind of feel like they're good people or
whatever I kind of felt like this guy
was a good guy it would not do something
like this by looking at his face yeah
that's the guy
but then looking at this face I don't
trust it looks different but I've seen
it in person he seemed like a good guy
what did he do exactly
they said he did a teaser video like he
put the teaser video I'd say what's he
do for Kevin why is he in his entourage
he's a stand-up comic so he's probably
one the guys that opens up for Kevin you
know he has like I think plastic cup
boys or something oh that's right so one
if someone in his crew actually how many
people help can we kind of have too many
of parts
private now but it's 13,000 followers I
bet look at them they're just trying to
mull over how to [ __ ] over his best
friend look at that picture
god damn it your curves basing over yeah
if your stand up and you extort Kevin
Hart we find out your piece of [ __ ] and
I'm the club owner I'm not giving my job
I'm like I'm set man also you'd be
honest one reason we're giving you part
of the gig excuse captain's friend know
you tried [ __ ] him over we definitely
can't have you here that makes me feel
so bad and also um again even though he
may be a bad he did a bad thing I hate
seeing someone that's that's that's the
destruction of a person see you later
deserve it though you're gonna distort
imagine if you enjoy stored money from
me yeah um that's why I want to tell you
I know that finding life's like I hit
this random text and that guy is me
and I know mind-blown your wife
PayPal me five a night I need a new pair
of shoes god I don't know man it's never
worth it please my guy sucks we all [ __ ]
up with us there's [ __ ] then there's a
bad person that's a bad person gonna get
rid of you I gotta get rid of you cuz
what you did is you plan something I'm
not to call my homies but I'm I've got
my new Hells Angel homies Minnesota
drive on down and stomp you out damn
well as we like to say you and me suck
in them they're so Jackson but it is an
actual video teaser about the sex tape
in real question I'm supposed so what
are you doing this situation like if
you're Kevin Hart you do exactly did I
do I extort me alright
I had six women I [ __ ] up wifey this
what happened I mean with with a friend
I'm guessing this is like a good friend
of his same attention like just
completely cut all no yeah no never no
no what if he found out friends in this
world one fell off about think about the
planning that went into this think about
you say they say you go hmm that's my
boy he's been really good to me I'm
going to videotape him having sex and
I'm going to I'm gonna get money he's
the most famous man in the world as far
as comedy goes most famous comic comic
in the world he's also probably the
second biggest movie star in the world
besides a rock right yeah and so I'm
gonna sit there come up with this plan
with these two [ __ ] chicken heads you
know what is it I think it looks like
jealousy so you watch your friend making
a million dollars a day then you go like
this you go you know what I want some of
that money that dude is making that much
money and I could really use some money
maybe my mother needs a house maybe
whatever you know what I'm gonna do this
is how dumb people are I'm gonna I'm
just gonna I'll videotape them I'll
threaten I'm not gonna make it public
but I'll threaten them with it and he'll
pay me and it'll be all good I'll just
do it quietly
do you know thank you find out this is
not a thinking person he's a [ __ ]
dum-dum who so so uh how about how about
a nice [ __ ] ride up was the grapevine
they go on to say Hart was unknowingly
videotape a mistake to the woman Las
Vegas last summer and
when the news broke he merely did damage
control by apologizing to his then
pregnant wife and made millions off the
scandal by going on tour making jokes
about being a habitual cheater oh I
don't know millions off of it don't
worry about this article though but but
but I you know when you're so I used to
have an acting teacher I said if you're
playing a guy like this you can't play
him like a bad guy you have to get into
his head and think about how he was
thinking about it I tend to be a good
guy well you think to yourself of the
way
he promises that he said I'm gonna do
I'm not gonna make it public but it's a
good way to make money quickly
that's all the reason why I ask that
because imagine like when your closest
friends you find out it has something to
do with it that's a tough thing to get
over to do that to Kevin though imagine
like someone super close to you did that
that would be and those guys so what I
did right along those guys were those
guys are always with him those guys are
his boys they're all good but maybe
maybe he's like a failing comic he's
like dude everyone tells me I'm the
funniest one in the group Kevin's making
all this money that is right now and I'm
gonna take this money from them
look it's your jealousy it's bad man
there's no other way to say you did a
bad I guess you have to cut him off I
can't believe he did that I'm glad about
this thing I know you just got that big
show you don't wire me 100 thousand
bucks I'm gonna release our text throw
I'm will restart extra video of you you
know doing what oh yeah shooting up bang
guys correct the heroin a few shows
I will sketch in this is just about
Kevin Lee I saw this recently it's the
most it's the craziest like viral edit
of Kevin doing the stanky leg wasn't
watching it's after he got kicked in the
head by Barbosa
even though yeah but this was just a
train right the only reason why we can
have fun with us cuz he won the fight we
would not be showing this on my drive he
won this fight so this is why we can
have a laugh at it we'd never show this
to a real fighter
I mean they went all out on this one
that's amazing it's a good video Jesus
Christ they put some time in there yeah
wow they really put time in this video
that was it yeah some guy named Roy
Rogers came in damn that's cool though
Kevin trucks up his Thank You Lightfoot
work to him recently taken ballet is
that true he said it helps them has his
footwork in the cage he's a very good
athlete with us kitchen
did you see Connors post about his
little kids birthday and his fat dick
hands yes it's not that crazy right post
hoc picture is right I went why is it
fogs together he does fat white dick
right there but look at his face - it's
so funny how he does it I feel like he's
doing this
nobody's doing that I think is a giant
fat hog or he just doesn't wear
underwear and he pulls it to the side
cuz you know what no he was a time when
she ate it well there's a bunch of the
shirt there appreciate his dick I
appreciate him miss kiddos Cuban okay
yeah the kiddos very good-looking fans
awesome he's awesome right yeah I'll be
back first well then this one too this
one's pretty crazy let me see this on
his dick I know he sold his kid on these
things like guys I think it's a fat dick
probably hopefully congratulations you
get this little that having a fat dick
Kratz cute ass kid yep the kids trying
to look like I'm two kids getting big
man thinking holy [ __ ] bags that's oh
that's Cox holy [ __ ] pics bro all the
comments are pretty much like nightly
shorts that got it when you have a good
dick day for family photo
see the third pick is hair i'ma get that
do didn't wear underwear that's that's
right he's not working did you see the
the comments on when I posted me blowing
out my jeans sometimes people have
[ __ ] hilarious on its grand what they
say just about my people are following
this the P were so funny will sketch in
this is from your hood Aurora Colorado a
woman put a year in sample into a
7-eleven microwave to warm it up and it
exploded so for thing that's
embarrassing it was for a job interview
I guess she was supposed to turn in a
sample and she wants to jail for this
but so she has to be like room
temperature or you know whatever 70 I
don't know how many degrees it is but it
has to be like warm year and she trying
to throw off like the testing so was his
thing when she got arrested she said
like but it's not real urine it's not
really urine so don't worry about it
that it exploded and got old and she
cleaned it up as much as she could
artificially and do you have to arrest
her though but then on top of that he
lost the guy cuz she admitted it wasn't
really urine it was fake urine I should
try to warm up so she didn't get the job
obviously look man that's a bother
you know no give her the job she's doing
everything it takes it takes she's not
bad like job no not give her the job I
really what was she trying to do just
getting it to the like he just urinated
into the except I wonder what job she
was applying for health clinic yeah she
looks like she fancies the drugs oh okay
let's look at this one embarrassing so
this guy he's been a sportscaster in the
Bay Area for over like twenty four years
and during a Warrior's practice game he
jacked one of the the jackets like it
was a I think of Stefan Curry's
bodyguards jacket like a warm look an
actual Warriors jacket that for whatever
reason this guy has Ralph Walker you
gotta know you're always on camera how
did they know this guy's this guy was
also why receiver for a team a long time
go Oh 40 runners names Mike Schumann
okay so and they're still on the jacket
and you can't do that obviously and you
can see am i doing see where's yeah
right there in the red but it looks like
that jackets just hair yeah but you
can't you can't take that so he loses
job you resign 20 years he resigned
after 24 years because of this man and
that's his resignation is it is with
sadness that I announced that ABC 7 News
and I have decided to amicably part ways
after 24 hours it was just a [ __ ]
jacket that he saw lie in there any
[ __ ] I want to taken it to I read
somewhere that the team is I know some
pair that deal you know that's not
stealing people because they have a lot
of those jackets and this from a big
organization it's just a jack and sure
you get swag all the time and yeah
million is like God my son wanted one of
these something I would take that to
[ __ ] off that's not stealing
oh he what he did was it right we should
lose his job baby news Oh what were you
gonna miss that jacket you just get
another one from the organizer you know
how it happens you go to the equip
manual hey I lost my jacket they'll cool
here's that's it hmm there's 100,000 it
cost exactly seven dollars to make [ __ ]
off I did hear that the teams were not
happy but like that's like a big deal to
them for some reason like he can't just
grab that job there he's a [ __ ] he's
there all the time he knows everybody I
don't know
hmm anyways well he's although my mom
saved my dad a lot of money a lot a lot
of money because this guy was trying to
get him to invest in a fund my mother
watched him kick a bar don't Bluff ball
and they did it without anybody says oh
she goes she goes he just cheated and
it's one thing to do it when people are
watching he did that and tried to get
away with it she goes I don't trust that
guy and you [ __ ] put your money and
his fun I will leave you she's right she
was right and it turned out he got
arrested he got arrested and he went to
jail and he he [ __ ] us what you look
tomorrow about 200 people what's what
you do when no one's looking right I
remember I found $20 like on the street
by this house
really young I came back and my dad look
at a $20 I was young like five or six
he's like where'd you get that Oh Mike I
found it on the street it's underneath
this stuff is like on like emanates like
a bunch of stuff you just go put it back
you know why you'll put it back that's
not your money don't take what doesn't
belong to you what do you do though like
I remember I was jogging at a place
called ma square park I saw $40 on like
a driveway there's where people walk and
jog all the time I I took it and then I
try to call like you know Moll Square
Park security whatever doesn't have to
do it nothing I couldn't get a hold
anyone yeah but but it goes back to that
very simple thing you learn as a kid
don't take what doesn't belong to you
and keep your promises that's what yeah
what kind of person you want to be flush
flush don't take what doesn't belong to
you keep your promises mmm if it's
yellow leave it mellow if it's brown
flush it down film your friends having
sex or the kitchen money later on that's
the way I was raised
okay I don't know if that if you're not
cheating you're not trying okay okay
okay all right
this one has been going around it you
can't see it that much but a guy in
India was killed by trying to take a
selfie with the bear that was injured
already oh so he laid down to take a
selfie like that was that after that's
after this is footage afterwards so I
guess they were on some sort of little
cruise thing during in this area they
stopped off because he had to pee and
then he also saw this bear that looked
injured and he wanted to take a selfie
with it that bear ended up attacking him
and killing him what the
you mean bears doing bear [ __ ] ooh this
is it this is it Oh play that video to
tell but you can see this is where the
bear already has them
and the cameras bad see it's what you
get those Crescent bears has a credits
an Asian Crescent er I think they call
it
cousin bear and it's just attacking the
guy yeah killing him yeah but that's
what you get unfortunately I hate to be
shitty about it oh [ __ ] he can't get
away huh you can't back up well this
time he has oh I think the bear has his
mouth on his hand sure it's a giant
[ __ ] man so here see my infertile
escape it the bear is i clamping down on
his hands [ __ ] I'm sorry
well I'm sorry tried to always wrestle
in the oh yes his hand oh that's tough
to watch the Bears wrestling the [ __ ]
dogs in you think the dog was going how
come no the humans are helping why is
just the dog helping
I don't know why the he was terrified
the dog bear could turn on you if you
don't know what to do anyways you can at
least draw the attention there's no foot
you of coke but of course but of course
this is a bear doing bear [ __ ] and let
me guess they killed the bear I think
they put it in a cage I'm sure they
killed it at this point but we gotta
have a gun you know eats those bears
so anyways there's that and I think this
is the end of it he's in a cage here and
he looks pretty messed up as is it's a
shame that killed him because that's on
that [ __ ] guy man that has nothing to
do with the bear if you're doing bear
[ __ ] you look close and take a selfie
with a bear the [ __ ] you thinking it's
like that guy with the black bear
receding from the grill and he's like
trying to get away from the bear wait
what happened it's a 400 pound animal or
whatever there's a bear killed oh no no
he was the bear was trying to steal from
his grill and he was I good away and he
was right there with his little tongs
it's like that bear probably weighs 250
looks like one the grizzly bear in arm
and I'd like you here Yeti microsphere I
didn't skip feeling hmm anyways so yeah
no [ __ ]
yep I'm not getting near the one that
made me sad was when Steve when Steve
Irwin died yes that was a shock all that
crazy [ __ ] you know how'd he die
stingray through the heart
yep how's a shock like right I don't cry
have you seen his daughter yeah she can
wrestle this dick in her mouth you know
what now I found a nice lady alright I
don't actually think she's that to me
yeah well I do another shrimp on the
barbie bring her another nut in your
mouth oh well alright but she's old
enough though bro
her Instagram how old is she
we may have dated this 1900 these not
know they're down under girl can't do it
hook these enough we can't do it she is
cute oh that's her [ __ ] man that's
Dancing with the Stars
okay can I sure not that's a leotard
give me a better picture
don't give me want her boyfriend's a
tool give me another one no all of us
are dead out of her dad
there was a video oh this is all
happening on the 26th of April and it's
such an honor
my entire family so if you're in our
life here I am with a [ __ ] Cobra mate
goodbye my neck thank you so much for
sending me yeah um does she do what he
does then yeah yeah if she does - that
she didn't focus stingrays anymore
though yeah well that was go back go
back let me see a croc that croc go down
go down go down down yeah right there
that croc no no no right there that's
that's her brother see her and her
brother doing the same [ __ ] her dad did
yeah that's a that's a big [ __ ]
that's a big salty don't [ __ ] around
with a salty alright yeah get away from
the salt ease that video sucked what
else move on chin she's hot though she
cute yeah no feel I don't know I don't
care
did you nineteen sometimes oh yeah she's
not your psoriasis ain't gonna help her
though 51 year old with psoriasis two
kids like 51 year olds with bumps all
over the [ __ ] face yeah I don't pump
brief I promise you a buffalo embrace it
it's a nightmare Brian what else you got
and my part teeth are not changing this
is in New Jersey a guy a superintendent
would take a dump on
football field every single day looks
like we kind of got what's the problem
so I was the problem here take it
brother football he would take a daily
[ __ ] on the football field it's exactly
my buddy who was a trainer in gym they
knew who the guy was they couldn't catch
him
he would come and work out all the poop
in it he would [ __ ] in the shower and
then he would walk out and go like this
and wait and they had to hold the other
trainer back from fighting and they said
and he was like don't fight him he's
like [ __ ] I know you're doing it and
he goes see ya and he would just come in
why do they do what does this guy do
this is what you want you so that's the
same reason I like to break into your
closet in your house and jerk off while
you're home that makes sense though this
makes this [ __ ] on your field that
is weird
well he was making a hundred and forty
seven thousand dollars so he just lost
that again these are crazy things to
lose didn't you say why it's just is
there's must be some sort of weird and
he makes a hundred grand a year
what was he upset about the [ __ ] on the
football field you know what maybe was
like cut as a kid on the football team
this was his way of getting back at or
it's just a perverse pleasure he takes
and he shits and Jack's I think it's a
condition I think it took in there he's
[ __ ] and dropping loads in the
blanks and leaving a piece of himself
everywhere and especially on the
football field because it's outraged and
it sorta has to clean it up outrageous
he's being a bad boy where's the
weirdest place you're taking the [ __ ] in
a mouth you're full of [ __ ] of course I
know I was like oh my god oh my god no
uh the weirdest place I've taken a [ __ ]
is just on the street and yeah I the
weirdest place that are taking the [ __ ]
on a roof once mmm that's really we had
to well because I had to well I was you
know Jay and I used to work for a rental
company so we drop off like party
rentals and James dish at know my friend
shake J was the truck driver we were a
young man and I had to [ __ ] so bad but
not like diarrhea like I had a straight
long yeah it had to come out yeah and
Jay was drinking a big old Slurpee yeah
and it was raining so hard outside and
we had to wait for the bill to come out
and I'm talking downpour like tropical
storm and I tell Jo
give me your contracts I'm just wired
give me
yeah Disney's Cup I go in the back I
drop a Cobra
yeah soft-serve Cobra in this giant
slurp began and jay is going for you so
that was in a truck yeah I got a food I
was uh I was young a long time ago my
mother's apartment New York City there
was a girl I brought her up to my my
mother's apartment and she's in the room
now it's a one-bedroom with a one
bathroom that was a morning and I
couldn't [ __ ] when she was there because
I didn't know her that I had to [ __ ]
something fierce oh you got the cramps
yeah that the [ __ ] sweats you been to
that apartment so I went to the kitchen
I closed the doors of the kitchen I
pulled out a plastic bag I shat in the
plastic bag hurry story white my
rumpy-pumpy put it in the plastic bag
tied it up and then put the plastic bag
out nasty that's too much trouble I'll
fall [ __ ] where if it that bad I just
have to get well my sister called me
after she was in college and she was I
don't like college I know why she's you
know I don't know really it's like guys
are very different than girls I said
what happened I was talking to guy he's
a very nice guy
he fell asleep on our couch and the guys
from the dorm next to us took a [ __ ] on
I want you he was lying there sleeping
and then I came out and he had a huge
coiled [ __ ] on his chest
it took a [ __ ] who would do that I was
like well what's this gym they're gonna
beat against college I was like not a
big deal yeah I guess on surveillance
they caught him passing by porta-potties
and toilets but he didn't want to poop
there so he just went to the field to
take a dump maybe like see [ __ ] outside
maybe grew up in the [ __ ] wilderness
or he's just into that some people like
to kill people
people like that rather rather it's the
people who like to have poo on them and
in them there's a documentary on Netflix
on which one is but is about kinky stuff
they interview these very attractive
girls thinking what's the weirdest thing
that you know that clients actually do
and this superhot girl goes
and she's like very reserved like I've a
normal client who I see on the regular
and he wants to share his mouth every
time I see him [ __ ] in his mouth I mean
I just could never do that that's how
crazy people are if Isis it was like hey
do you want all the homies [ __ ] in your
mouth and we'll let you free or we're
gonna slit your throat just slit my
throat yeah yeah that's what people are
into the Holies of [ __ ] in your mouth
man but if she's really hot no kidding I
don't know that's I can't that stuff off
throw up someone showed me a video when
times got a glass tube with a funnel and
then people chit in the tube you're
supposed to do that you're supposed to
throw up calling scat babes
why don't you got you how cool
have you guys have you guys ever seen
someone get jacked for their shoes I
mean I've heard of it it's definitely
pretty common so here's a video of it
they thought these are $2,000 Air
Jordans turns out Allen mm ah
Jordan ones are so many of the originals
mm some 11 patent leathers or some just
say which ones there mmm I'll find out
the name of it okay this isn't flushing
so I'd let you watch the video real
quick so there's a car looking at this
dude just on his phone on the sidewalk
in his JS mm-hmm so the car oh you know
what they might be the iCube girl yeah
so the car just like parks on a curb and
then take his shoes three people run up
to the guy did they have a gun or
anything no nothing so they just watch
this look how they do it
this guy just tackles I'm from the back
how the guy just goes for his shoes oh
yeah
so it looks like they're just after the
shoes straight up and then they just
book it they take off throw him to the
side they take off oh yeah she was taken
and the guy actually comes chasing after
him which I thought was pretty like a
rave racket yeah yeah suited to a cell
phone I'm just taking pictures of
license well like minutes later they try
to steal those three guys try to steal
steal sell the shoes at a shoe place
that's crazy so they're not they're not
awful that's a weird in there on video
and that's them going to the counter to
sell these two thousand two thousand
dollar ordinance lares whoa that's the
other one
alright so oh I thought that was a cop I
was like geez relax anyways the guy at
the counter said no these are fake so
they jacked this dude for Jordans that
were knockoff Wow yeah this the counter
guy said that they were completely calm
like they didn't you know they were just
like pros at this they've done it so
many times probably legs so they jacked
fake one so now that [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
don't think they're caught yet either
I don't think the cops are exactly hot
on the case we better figure this out
man let's get our top detectives on it
that's been going on in New York for as
long as I can remember
oh man I mean people my buddy said I'd
caught you go what's your size first
thing they'd say yeah what's your size
yeah I remember kids the the Jordan
threes and the Phi's my mom was like you
know uh after school he come home in
those things and change shoes get him
strong yeah that it chin that's pretty
well there's one little I bet you he had
those ones those second those are the
ones that you see the second ones in
there those Jordan one I was at $2,700
yes
y-yeah there's their limited especially
those that's ridiculous
we talked these ones are so sick how are
they why
yeah well half white brain cuz the only
made a few of them and it's very [ __ ]
stupid and that's stupid well make a few
and sell for that much hilarious
scarcity yeah but you like wine right
that's like my your bottle where Ron's
great that doesn't use those aren't good
dessert for us they are like you like
some bottles of wine right those are
super rare no those are an original okay
so how is this any different no just
hear me out a great wine taster onus
marketing right one it's like scarcity
and marketing and they're not really
that interesting let's be honest they
are though cuz here you don't know
you're talking about this like me talk
about wine I would love to see me out
him out the read that the reason
why those are cool that was the first
shoe that Jordan wore that was the first
that kind of made shoes cool and Jordan
got fine by the NBA cuz he wasn't
allowed to wear his own shoe okay so
that's what those stand for it right so
they recreate him this Virgil hunter
recreated these shoes in that and the
super sign now I understand it's so
different than why I still be I do
doping is so different than wine in a
way it's not because some people say
that they can sit wine experts down and
give them the most immense wine in the
world and the cheapest we can't tell the
difference you know that's not true
because great wine is like an art form
right so great wine takes like it's so
hard like when you drink those top wines
it's like an experience you know and you
go holy [ __ ] is the best one I've ever
had this is very wearable say when you
put those little shoes when you put
those on it's just kind of like I don't
know I mean you know that you're being
duped into a marketing scam that's what
that's not true be that what that's like
saying wine you've no - no because wine
is it then why do you have six hundred
dollars shoes on because why don't you
well these are giving no no they weren't
by the way they weren't your wife bottom
no we have come about common projects
for 400 yeah
why don't you wear pay less because I
like nice I think nice shoes there's a
change in quality quality yeah so those
shoes the guy who designed those Virgil
hunter who's now the head of Louis
Vuitton is the hottest designer in the
world he's the most he's literally not a
designer I am so the quality and time he
puts into those shoes are made by a
designer there's no that that's why
they're so expensive not like you don't
think he's taking a spin on that shoe I
got and turn it into something different
I mean but 2,700 bucks is pretty crazy
the thing about wine that you just drink
once yeah I can keep these on the value
of these actually go up wow that's an
investment right I mean if I understand
people buying something like jewelry or
shoes because it's a fashion statement
it's made by a certain designer and
stuff that that's a little bit different
I mean I you know I don't know but I
would still think 2,700 bucks is a
fuckload of money for shoes man a lot
but it's not for wine I would never bet
it about that far that's the thing if
you're into wine if you're into cheese
for your in fashion to dinners you know
I'm saying it's it's all relative right
like do whoever buys these that's their
thing they're under those that name
what's the best one I will give
by a coat that's made a designer coat
that's made by a specific designer
you're gonna that's just what they're
into you don't saying and you and again
a lot of times my special roller what
you're saying is those are a work of art
they're made by this little ad for me of
course maybe because I'm old they look
like regular sneakers you know I'm sorry
with wine if you give me about a wine I
go yeah I don't give a [ __ ] how much
that one you know out the other teeth or
thing yeah yeah that makes it it's just
what you know but to hate on it like
that I hate on that you like wine no no
but I just think twenty seven hundred
bucks is twenty seven bucks is because
they're so scarce they're so rare rice
ball cards you know those are worth so
much but it's a collector's idea and if
it's made by this guy then you know it's
like you would spend a lot on believe at
all cuz you're buying a specific thing
he's the designer for Louisa Tom Virgil
a bow yeah he so he so his story is he
start off with Kanye him and Kanye start
off together and then he went to Nike
did this white label thing that's blown
up and then he just got hired by Louie
Vuitton so it's like poor thing yes this
what's interesting is so boy he's
putting a spin on the classic so then
what's interesting is this Virgil a blow
Virgil a bow because these don't look
like much but they're handmade by this
guy for Golden Goose and they fear
they're comfy but see this this room
table who now to the in so what's
interesting here so now he has such a
different perspective on like these
classics so Louie Vuitton hires him
right he's the top design for a
live-time now and that's kind of they
would you what do you think him in the
job and Connie got upset at him kind of
because they should be best friends yeah
he was well the reason why I got into
fascist cuz I want make it available to
the masses like no one everyone be able
to afford nice cool stuff
Louis Vuitton no one can afford that
yeah so he went he's going off our route
like and they go what about the Yeezys
like they're six hundred ology goes
that's not no that's what the reason why
I left Nike I want them to make so many
shoes everyone can have okay so they
keep they can make money by making these
literally islands and by the way it was
virtually well guess what when you do
make those shoes people find a way to
buy them even people with no money that
might be who is big so so when you make
something really expensive and exclusive
the people that don't have money are
going to
because it's a status M and can you see
and that's the problem
yeah much crazy [ __ ] Kanye says he's
right and this goes well now he cuz this
Virgil anything he touches is the
hotness so now he makes Louie Vuitton so
kids we messed in the pants for Louie
Vuitton yeah who's that's not what we
want we don't people to idolize Louie
Vuitton which $1,000 for a pair of shoes
exactly but it'll always be that way
right there all the time people want
nice things that nobody else has that's
a human thing because it's so expensive
that it's not because they don't make
enough of it yeah so expensive only a
fraction of the world but when you buy
wine you Peter Michael makes a certain
number of wines only and then then they
people drink them and then there are six
bottles left the price goes where the
[ __ ] up so you know people want them
it's very strange
guys doing it's because it's like like
that your radio shooting all he wrote
was air like you know in the air strange
but he's like you said still if you're
into fashion I can't argue with it if
you're into fashion and you're into a
certain look then you know I used to I
used to make fun of fashion and I
realize I wouldn't want to live in a
world without it because it makes the
world very colors just what you're into
it's all sorted like when I went to it
well to wine tasting the guy would shut
up I'm like Jesus Christ most here's a
[ __ ] nerd I see myself this is so
lame like you're into grapes not [ __ ]
but then you get appreciate for I'm like
how's that any different than me being
obsessed with [ __ ] yeah cuz it's an art
form yeah just eat I would listen to it
all day because I love it yes I want
shoes but I'm like I'm like a hey like
that's his thing like that's cool
she was our form of decoration a form of
artistic expression so when you put a
dog on stupid ones out there but yeah
yeah but I get it it's a new dad shoe
going on right now I just can't get on
that hype train that's the high - the
dad shoe type in dad shoe I see I don't
mind though this is pretty cool right
those are cool let me show this one
though it's [ __ ] it's literally
called dad shoe also that I'm here
click very first one
and they're selling out everywhere yeah
and I got a draw those are those are oh
yeah I'm all sold out who makes those
those are those Bella where they come by
length yeah yeah oh I saw someone wear
these although that does it tomorrow or
should I took a picture of two you know
mean Delia in the shoe that th one hot
shoe in this game right now
really and he goes nah how does that
happen so how does it happen ready yeah
I need to know know who made those hot
honey West because he warts are where
I'm you warm he has the dad look so
Tonya started the dad hats he started he
started the light colored jeans shoes so
he may he wore is him because apparently
Kylie Jenner were my my wife's cousins
dress she couldn't allow demand no I
mean and when you become a personality
like that you start wearing [ __ ] you can
make a fortune just wearing stuff right
just a p40 a lot of money and Connie has
such an influence now so instead of
doing New York Fashion Week and all that
stuff well you know he did to release
his new line since his wife is always in
the spotlight he sure went oh you're
going to get a juice one of my new shirt
and then she oh you're going to get gas
wear my new shirt are you gonna give
this weird this so his fashion he used
them damn so smart why not why wouldn't
you god damn I I can't get in those dad
chose a yeah draw the line somewhere
that's where I stopped at I can't do the
dad shoes she looks great what else get
Jen there's this it's not a huge deal
it's just some older grandfather guy
that I saw police chase and then he's
has a cane so you can't really walk that
well but he actually tripped this Rob
Rousey is running by yeah and I mean the
guy was armed - so it could have been a
lot worse
oh really yeah so there's a police
chasing on this body cam
to shoot the guy not so you see there's
a huge chase going on and there's a
grandfather right there there's a better
shot coming up this box up little boom
trypsin I move grandpa back leg boom
[ __ ] good trap Elias yeah that was your
scene that guy so that's been a wheel
kick when that guy stole that woman's
purse that was the worst I'm telling
everybody now that it's time for lunch
yes well why'd you do that
I said yes all right let's do it oh yeah
let's go eat some lunch
go on droppin stuff all right let's go
[ __ ] on football fields for no reason at
all
let's go poo poo on the top of toilets
speaking of [ __ ] on football fields hey
I'm being Houston June twenty twenty
seconds not gonna [ __ ] on football
fields but I'm gonna [ __ ] on that stage
damn right Jay twenty to twenty seconds
Houston improv defect kake.com tickets
are officially on sale for Talia hall
and Chicago July 20th where I am
shooting my special Brendan Schaub will
be opening for me we're gonna be having
some good times July 20th come see me at
the end of the month March 31st June 1
June 2
Minnesota where Brennan and the Hells
Angels were hanging out
I totally ruin you every kind of ended
with you coming two weeks
you're awesome yeah come out and see me
deep fat kid come for brother myself yes
sir
new sandal ain't Ortiz drop Wednesday
night the vintage Excitebike tees drop
Wednesday night 5:00 p.m. Pacific tak
calm this is a fine kid we're out